pleased to have here on the program his
new film uh my dad's christmas date is
in theaters and on demand
today he plays the role of the
aforementioned dad
he is jeremy piven how are you jeremy
good how are you sir
it's been a minute it has been a minute
uh let's start with the sports let's do
that
um let's do it your thoughts on your
chicago bears i give you the floor
on the bears jeremy well you know i just
got a call from them
and i i have a tryout for offensive card
because we we uh we're three out of five
downs
right now
now they need a five foot nine jewish
offensive guard
apparently and i am i am ready rich as
you know i am ready yes indeed you've
seen me
i have seen you i've never seen you uh
uh
you know on some sort of running pulling
situation i've never seen that but i'm
going to trust you
you have that first step ability no no
sir if you if you remember correctly
you were there we had a big flag
football game that was televised live on
espn
yes and um i have great lateral movement
i need to celebrate myself for a moment
well you know uh
your coach matt neggie does have that
phrase be you and if that's who you are
then
i think you i think you need to get to
uh tennessee right away because that's
that's gonna be a tough one coming up
this weekend for your best it will
listen it will be a tough one but isn't
this
one of those moments where like you know
a player
on the practice squad who who has been
the best player on every field he's
ever walked onto gets his moment isn't
this the
time i'm confused are you rudy you're
the rudy of the chicago 2020 chicago
bears is essentially what you're saying
right now
no no what i'm saying is there is not me
we've moved on
okay we've moved on from that bit i'm
sorry i didn't yeah no no it's all right
okay i'm just saying
there there our offensive line you know
is challenged and
there are some guys that are going to be
stepping up
and you know trubisky you know has been
moved to back up and he
he played one play got injured it
happens
i don't mean to laugh but i mean it is
it is it is kind of crazy in that regard
but i mean it and
it's it is like watching teeth get
pulled
this offense trying to get some points
on the board jeremy but it
you never know this thing can change in
a heartbeat and foles might be the guy
to do it
you just never know listen he he's he's
a
a quarterback there's have an incredible
defense so anything's possible
jeremy piven here uh on the rich eisen
show um
okay so are you in a fantasy team or
just you watch the bears and that's
basically about it
well i you know i'm a fan of reality i
don't need to fantasize about football
players nice but
but if you want to spend you know every
waking moment here
you know then i i celebrate you okay for
doing that
i don't do i don't do a lot of fantasy
okay very good so you're more
steeped in reality during this uh
crazy-ass quarantine of we're staying at
home
what of yours from the your your your
work
television movies that you flip the
television on you saw
on the screen like oh i forgot i did
that does that happen any point in time
last several months you know i don't i
don't ever go
i forget but like you know the other
night you know they're showing old
school
on cbs it was like the sunday night
movie they're bringing back
and you know it's one of those movies
that never gets old it was great to see
so old school was uh was actually on
on network television is a sunday night
movie that actually happened
it happened that's amazing holy crap um
some of the things i want to talk with
you about uh before we get to your your
your your film is when was the last time
you did watch an episode of entourage
when was the last time that happened
well you know it
it you know exactly how long it's been
but
what's interesting is people in real
time keep reaching out about it
you know when you guys coming back
what's going on we miss you
and then they'll send me you know like
instagram stories
they'll send me scenes you know a
therapy scene of
ari gold and mrsari where ari is losing
his mind
and they'll so i i kind of it's it's
being brought to my attention all the
time
i think because you know people miss it
which is
makes me feel good that we had an impact
but i think also time in these times
where everyone is is trying is on their
best behavior
that represents the time when um
it was an authentic show ari the
character of ari was an equal
opportunity offender
and you know it was just simpler times
where we're having a good laugh and we
weren't necessarily
worried about who we were offending who
was the best athlete guest star
that uh as for an actor who who had the
best chops jeremy
that showed up shops that's a that's a
great question thank you the best
chops as an actor well i'll tell you
this when mike tyson
uh when he showed up he had a very
he had a very specific idea of how he
wanted to play it
um and and then he and i
i you know he's
he's the great mike tyson the youngest
heavyweight champion and he's making his
return
uh yes as you know yes because you know
the gods of war have ignited my ego
which is fantastic the gods of
war have ignited i think he needs to sit
on a couch and play god of war
and maybe ignite his barbecue i don't
know but he's back and we're excited
um he ultimately was kind of the best
performer
because he he he and i worked together
and i got him improvising
and then he just ultimately crushed it
i've got jeremy piven here
on the rich eisen show let's talk about
my dad's christmas date uh
you and jolie richardson and uh natalie
cox and anna walton
uh i give you the floor on did you shoot
this in london
or it was just uh this this was all shot
there right
just out of a couple hours outside of
london okay
is this brilliant town called york and
it's
you know it's i don't know if they wrote
it
with this town in mind but it's this
magical place where
it has castles and it's authentic and
it's beautiful and it feels like
christmas
and i play a guy who lost his wife and
he's trying to connect with his daughter
and you know they haven't dealt with
their grieving process
and so it's awkward and he's trying too
hard and
he's a mess and the daughter takes it
upon herself to
try to kind of get the get her old man
to
kind of connect with love and she goes
and she's very cheeky and goes online
and sets him up on all these dating
sites
and suddenly he's on it he doesn't even
know it
and hilarity ensues it's um it's one of
those movies that
you think it's going to be one thing and
it becomes another it's really funny and
edgy and heartfelt and i'm pretty proud
of it
and again it's uh my christmas date is
in theaters and on demand today
um with you jeremy piven before before i
uh i'll let you go
um some may not uh know or
remember um because they're too damn
young
um that entourage was not your first hbo
foray you were an integral part of one
of the greatest shows in the history of
television the larry sanders show what
was it like
being around gary shandling for all of
that jeremy
it was really cool you know to make a
sports analogy
it would have been like being on
on the bulls in the 90s right and i and
i knew it because
i grew i did grow up in chicago and i
grew up on the stage and
i am a stage actor and so i
i had a a reference for comedy
um at second city and all that stuff i
started with a guy named chris farley
a million years ago um in the second
city touring company so i had a
reference for comedy
so i knew how good he was and how good
that show was
and i was the guy was coming off the
bench i was like craig hodges
on the chicago bulls and so i knew that
i was surrounded by greatness
and i was lucky to be there and i just
soaked it all up and it was incredible
and he was a genius and that show
launched
original programming on hbo so i was
incredibly lucky to be around it
there is i mean every second of that
show
is like a drop of honey on the planet
like literally
every every scene every word
you know just ev the ac you and the rest
of that cast
was just perfection riptorn was crazy
right i mean was he totally nuts
being around him on that set well i you
know first of all god rest his soul
right and
he was i i we he
it was a last of a dying breed let's say
that i mean he
he was from texas and he was obviously
you know this desperate master thespian
but like you know
uh a guy that would was not afraid of
trouble
in any way shape or form i remember one
time he came back from lunch
and he had taken off his toupee and was
shaking out
what looked like glass out of his toupee
and he said that someone had shattered
his windshield and he got into some
altercation
and he just kind of just got the
windshield out of his
toupee and just put it right back on and
just
got back into the scene without missing
a beat
that is definitely a great rip torn
story you got a good farley one
since you just mentioned that uh you
broke in with him
well farley was one of these guys you
know you know like riptorn who
was such an authentic
character that lived his life to the
fullest and uh
so we would perform at second city and
then you would go out
until a million o'clock and you would
drink and
chicago is open till four o'clock and
five o'clock on saturday nights
and so on a saturday night you'd you'd
you know go to the pub and
do your thing and crush it and then go
to sleep
but i just remember seeing him going to
the gas station to get
a mac and cheese at dawn and he just
played through
and i just tapped out and you know
he played through it's a great way to
put it he played through
a morning mac and cheese from a gas
station yeah he did
he did it and he was also quite an
athlete
um as you could tell he was a rugby
player
at loyola and you know
he was about a biscuit over 300 pounds
but he was still very flexible yeah you
could see he was definitely nimble
uh hey jeremy speaking of nimble i look
forward to watching you uh
uh create some holes for david
montgomery on sunday against the
tennessee titans
um that sounds both enticing
and dirty it just sounds awkward
so let me put it this way uh i
appreciate i look forward to you pass
blocking for nick foles uh
on uh sunday against uh tennessee uh and
then everybody can check out my dad's
christmas date in theaters and on demand
today thanks for the call jeremy you
take care thank you sir take care of
yourself right back at you that's jeremy
piven
jacob go bears there you go